Cody says, what about the ones that refuse to do Zoom
or don't know how, what do you mean?
Like, it's not, I don't give them an option, Cody.
I just say, hey man, let's do a Zoom.
We're gonna be doing a Zoom.
And they're like, oh, I just wanna talk on the phone.
That's not how it roll, that's not how I roll.
I want you to see my face.
I wanna like know who you are.
If I'm gonna work with you, I wanna see who you are
and I wanna talk to you on a Zoom call.
It's really hard.
You see, I'm gonna send you this link.
It's gonna be a text and you're gonna push,
it's gotta underline, you know what that is, right?
Push that and you should be good to go, okay?
Maybe you tell them to download Zoom, whatever.
It's not an option, okay?
Cody, answer your question.